you
[Music]
okay we'll get started a little early
thanks for everyone everyone's coming so
early this morning having breakfast with
us so they've been rising calls to
investing more attention in the
potential disruptions good and bad that
might come out of advances in artificial
intelligence there's been waves of
disruption in the past over over
centuries this one's a bit different in
in a number of ways per the competencies
were seeing in that they read on and
read directly on capabilities around
human intellect and so much of what's
human in human labor hinges on our
ability to think reason predict and so
on so there's been increasing
scholarship and opinions most of which
are under great uncertainties and matter
how confident people might look about
the future including influences of
various kinds of advances in AI and it's
a big field with different sub
disciplines including machine learning
on the nature of tasks the distribution
of jobs and so on so today we've invited
several deep thinkers to join us to
share their reflections about the future
of work labor and the economy and so
we'll be welcoming David autor James
mineka Jason Furman Sid Surrey and
Stephan Dirk on and each will share
about 10 minutes of their perspectives
on a set of questions that I'll mention
that I well I lost it in some email with
them last week before I start though I
want that I just make a comment about
this the the challenges with with
predicting the future to frame the
conversation here I like to bring up
these interesting sketches by jean-marc
Cote who did these in 1899 thinking
about the future of what technology
would bring to the world the future of
home automation electric scrubbing this
idea of what how automation would affect
work in this case what barbers would be
like in the future
by the way lon
Jameel the year 2000 here so we're
looking into the future
no 18 years ago okay but here's a very
busy farmer in the future and then some
of these things are kind of not so far
off in terms of what was the B thought
this was a little bit odd at school
so you basically take this is the
Coursera logo picture here putting books
into a machine and turning the Machine
and then educating people and so on but
but one thing is interesting and for
sure we do know a bunch about the past
when it came to waves of technical
innovation so Thomas Newcomen and the
Newcomen steam engine was an early
version of a steam engine that led to
big changes in how industry works
including how cloth was was was weaved
and there was a big reaction to the loss
of certain kinds of jobs that people had
trained for and had spent their lives
doing and many generations doing so much
so that the Luddites and folks being
being as frustrated as these Luddite saw
as they were referred to we're called
started breaking machines actually and
it's so much so or frame breaking so
much so that in 1812 there was a British
law that that that gave the death
penalty to people seen breaking machines
and the reaction to this law was from
this from some of the people here we
will never lay down arms and so the
House of Commons passes an act to put
down all machinery hurtful to the common
people and repeal that law to hang frame
breakers and you some people have argued
that other ways of automation are behind
for example the rise of Marxism and the
Cold War of course we hear a lot about
this today
even now automation of various kinds
even even Preedy pieces of AI being
behind a widening gap in so with that
said I like to invite up our guests now
to say a pipe them up maybe if you can
fit in that order if you remember it but
if you don't don't worry about sitting
in the order and we'll just go with you
sit down here so in a pleat the
deston I mentioned several questions now
this was new because the part of our
guests questions
what are challenges and opportunities
ahead with advances in AI landmark to
labor in the economy what the active
abilities will have the most influence
what are key concerns and how might we
proactively address them what are the
risks of four scenarios what are the
sub-sites what indicators or data should
we be collecting in monitoring closely
what can we learn from previous jumps is
on people in society what went well
versus poorly in the past what is
different this time referring to one of
jason the title of one of Jason's talks
a couple years ago how will different
regions and cultures be influenced and
then finally cuz I know that you can't
avoid this so thinking ahead of time
what might surprise us looking back 30
years from now so with that let me just
tell you Jesus who we have here and in
the in the first seat is David autor
he's a four professor in the MIT
Department of Economics and David has
explored the influence of technological
change and globalization on labor
markets he has received numerous awards
for a scholarship and his teaching
National Science Foundation Career Award
Alfred P sloan Foundation fellowship
Sherwin Rosen prize for outstanding
contributions in the field of labor
economics he did his BA at in psychology
at Tufts and a PhD in public policy from
Harvard's Kennedy School of Government
next is James muñeca he's a senior
partner at McKinsey & Company and he's
chairman and director of the McKinsey
Global Institute and this is the
Mackenzies Business and Economics
research arm he's LED boots on digital
economy AI in the future of work as well
as productivity and globalization
he was appointed by President Obama as
vice chair of the Global Development
Council at the White House and by the US
Commerce Secretary's to the digital
economy board he serves on the board of
the Council on Foreign Relations
McArthur foundation and your foundation
and he's a as a Rhodes Scholar went off
to to do a
his um his PhD work at Oxford and we've
had talks about this before actually so
he's he fit right at the MSR here with
his background in robotics mathematics
and computer science you get a
bachelor's a University of Zimbabwe as
an anglo-american scholar next is Jason
Furman he's the professor of the
practice of economic policy at Harvard
Kennedy School he's also a non-resident
senior fellow of all these things mean
and whether it's the non-resident senior
fellow they don't have those at MSR at
the Peterson Institute for an
international international economics
this followed eight years as a top
economic adviser to President Obama
including his service as the 28th
chairman of the Council of Economic
Advisors acting as both President
Obama's chief economist and a member of
the cabinet jason is connected research
on a wide range of areas including
fiscal policy tax policy health
economics social security and domestic
and international macroeconomics and in
addition to publishing widely in
journals he is editing two books on
economic policy he did his PhD in
economics at Harvard and then a very own
Sid Sri as a senior researcher at MSR AI
and citizen is a social scientist of the
computational variety whose work lies at
the intersection of computer science
behavioral economics and crowdsourcing
and the kick economy
his early work analyzed the relationship
between network topology and human
behavior and what recently has been he's
been studying gig workers who power up
many applications and enhance the way
Bing works and and and Google and so on
by tagging content he just finished a
book with other MSR researcher in New
York City entitled ghost work how to
stop Silicon Valley from building a new
global underclass and this book is due
out in in May of this year and Sid
earned his PhD in computer science from
the University of Pennsylvania in 2007
and finally and this is
they're very different perspective now
the Stefan will bring Stefan Turk on is
professor of economic policy at the
Blavatnik School of Government and the
economics department there he's a fellow
of the Jesus College at the University
of Oxford and director of the University
Center for the Study of African
economies a few years back he was chief
economist of the department of
international development this is the
governmental department in charge of the
UK's aid policy and spending and his
concern his interests are around the
failures of markets governments and
politics mainly in Africa and how to
achieve change there and he also has a
late-breaking book called dull disasters
how planning ahead will make a
difference and in some ways this whole
panel is about planning ahead or
thinking ahead to maybe take some
actions that might make the world go a
bit better Stefan is currently the
academic director of pathways for
Prosperity in Commission on technology
and inclusive development chaired by
Melinda Gates and funded by the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation so with that is
great BIOS and I only read portions of
the BIOS you have in your email believe
it or not so I want to start with David
I guess just ten minutes to reflect on
some of those questions and we'll just
go down the line and then open it up to
Q&A great thank you very much it's it's
a it's a pleasure it's an honor to be
here thank you for inviting us and so
I'm not going to you know telling you
about AI and all that you know that
better than I so let me try to give you
an economic perspective on how I see the
interaction between automation
technological advance and and labor
markets and that both the challenges and
opportunities they present so you know
it's useful to start off by recognizing
that that most of the great advances the
great technological advances of the last
200 years have been directed at saving
labor right so you know tractors were
invented to you no substitute for
machine and animal muscle muscle power
the assembly line was built to eliminate
repetitive human labor and replace with
machine precision and computing was
created to you know automate you know
cumbersome error-prone human calculation
and do it with digital perfection and
and these ideas these technologies have
worked right we don't we don't you know
dig did
is by hand we don't pound tools out of
wrought iron we don't do bookkeeping
using books these are all done
mechanically automatically and so these
have been enormous success an enormous
amount of labour has been displaced from
those formerly labor intensive
activities yet in that 200 year period
we have not run out of jobs or anything
close to it the fraction of the the
adult population that works in the paid
labor force has exceptions and a lot of
that by the way is the entry of women
into the paid labor force out of a
grueling repetitive very limited and not
monetarily compensated house working to
a richer set of possibilities so running
so I'm not concerned personally about
the world running out of jobs and you
know a short answer why hasn't that
occurred one is that even as machines
substitute for a subset of the tasks
that we used to do they tend to
complement that which remains they
increase the value of our expertise of
our judgment of our creativity and
increase the leverage we which we
exercise those capabilities and and our
flexibility and problem-solving skills
and so they can make labor more valuable
in the tasks that remain and similarly
because people are insatiable our rising
incomes does not cause us to feel like
we have enough you know the the typical
worker in 2015 could earn the the middle
class standard of living of 1915 by
working kind of 18 weeks a year and but
people don't choose to do that they
choose to work hard because they want
the standard of living that is available
for today's hard work um so so that's a
kind of a rosy overview but let me now
qualify that with an a set of concerns
so many people are sort of vaguely aware
of those facts and say ah so the lesson
of history is don't worry about it this
problem will take care of itself right
and I think that's actually that's not
the right lesson of history there's
another there's another lesson of
history of course which is that we're
doomed we're about to get run run over
and you know this time is different and
you know to which I will
always globally say every time is
different so that's not kind of
meaningful it's more useful to ask in
what way is it different than what you
would be concerned about but if we think
about the adaptations to prior ways of
automation there have been some really
important ones and they didn't happen on
their own so in the you know late 1800s
and early 1900s agricultural employment
was falling at the rate of about a half
percentage point per year in the United
States so 38 percent of all US
employment was on farms in 1900 today
it's well under 2 percent and and that's
a function of technological progress
because of improvements in irrigation in
genetics in machinery and and in other
forms of science on it now just takes a
couple million people to feed a
population of over 300 million and
export lots of food so that's great but
there really there are many fewer
agricultural jobs necessarily and um
peat farmers looked around and they saw
the fact that they're a potential crisis
was looming their children were no
longer going to be needed on the farm
and yet they were not prepared for the
next thing the next thing that was
rising at that time of course was
industry and so many US states did
something quite radical they passed laws
that said their kids needed to stay in
school until the age of 16 and that was
radical because you know one you had to
build buildings you had to hire teachers
you had to buy books but even more
radically you had to send your kids to
school so they couldn't be working in
the farm from age you know 9 or 10
forward as they otherwise would have
been and that was considered frivolous
in its time many Europeans look to us
and said that's crazy
you know why does everyone need to be
both literate and numerate you know and
is everyone really capable of that level
of you know academic accomplishment and
it turned out to be one of the most
forward-looking
decisions policy decisions that u.s.
made in the 20th century arguably gave
us the most agile the most productive
the most flexible work force and it was
led by the farm states by the states
that were losing agriculture than most
rapidly so at a critical juncture in
history the u.s. made the decision to
invest in its citizens and that made
that that instead of making their labor
therefore you know redundant it made
them enable them to be productive in a
much more mechanized much more
scientific workplace so that's you know
so so the lesson I take from that is
that we faced a challenge and we made
forward-looking decisions we made
investments that made us complimentary
to the to the technology rather than
substitutable by it so now let me talk
briefly about what I see as the current
challenge um the the big challenge in my
in my view that we face in the
industrialized world is that the the
nature of work has been radically
hollowed out by the process of
automation that on the one hand if you
look at the growth of job structures
look at occupations they look like sort
of a barbell with increasing poundage on
either end of the bar on the one side
you see professional technical
managerial jobs what you do what we do
and there's never been so many great
jobs and these are highly educated jobs
they have a lot of job security because
the skills are scarce and differentiated
and they're creative and they're
interesting and they're endure without
heavy lifting on the other hand you see
a lot of growth of low education low
training personal services you know food
service cleaning you know health care
entertainment and what is contracting is
a lot of office clerical administrative
work and a lot of production and
operative work and what the forces
behind that are no longer mysterious
right many of those middle skill middle
education jobs followed well understood
rules and procedures that can
increasingly be codified in software and
accomplished by machines whereas many of
the tasks you do are much harder in
person service tasks require dexterity
flexibility you know common sense that
are still as you know and so that
hollowing out has kind of missing the
ladder of opportunity arguably shrunk
the size of the middle class and it's
been particularly actually consequential
in dense urban areas it used to be that
in dense urban areas non-college workers
did much more skilled work they did
production work or they did office with
and now they don't there's no gradient
in that anymore they do service work
they're basically there
for the care and comfort of the Ethel
and that's a enormous problem in my
opinion and I'm running out of time so
let me let me make two final comments
one I you know my my colleagues drone
Acemoglu and Pasquale Restrepo who's a
MIT student who's now at Boston
University they made a very useful set
of distinctions in thinking about how
does ought what of the automation do and
many of us in economics are trained to
think of automation as complementing
workers but I think there's another way
to think about it that they emphasize I
think is very useful automation almost
necessarily means taking a set of tasks
that were done by people and having them
done by another mechanism you could and
and so that has two effects one is it
displaces workers from some set of
activities and the other is it raises
proactivity because there's other things
are now being done more effectively but
you can have automation that has a lot
of displacement without a lot of
productivity benefit all right so let me
give you an example of that the phone
tree an airline or the self-checkout
thing at Home Depot right
those are nightmare technologies they do
nothing good why do companies use them
because they're a little bit cheaper
then the workers they replace and they
don't degrade the quality of the product
from the point of view of the customer
that much that it's not worth you know
taking that hit so you can displace a
lot of Labor doing that without actually
making much of a dent in productivity
and that's the kind of worst case
scenario you would like to if you're
going to displace workers you'd like to
have a much better product and that
creates output and that creates
opportunity for growth and so it's
possible to have a lot of change without
a lot of protip t growth and arguably
we've been in that period recently so
final comment
I'm not nearly as worried about this
problem for the developed industrialized
world as I am for the rest of world
because we actually are getting much
more educated many of us will be doing
the type of work that is complemented
and because of the scarcity of Labor and
the demographic change those who don't
are educate for that there'll be
enormous demand for their services
however in the developing world
as I'm sure Stephan will elaborate what
a lot of people in developing world do
is do labor intensive services for the
rich world whether that's making you
know textile and other goods and
fabrics whether that is answering phone
calls whether is that it's exporting
domestic workers to do care work
cleaning work or construction work and
it's possible that as artificial
intelligence an automation makes us much
more self-sufficient in the rich world
that will devalue the labor endowment of
a lot of gelatine countries so I think
the challenges are very significant and
there's although automation necessarily
raises incomes and creates opportunity
meaning it can make us all wealthier the
process by which that the benefits from
that are shared or not shared is not a
function of the market it's not a
function of technology it's a function
of societal choices about how to
allocate and adapt to those resources so
the lesson of history is that we stand
at a critical juncture there's
opportunity and challenge and we should
not think it will take care of itself
itself but there are many possibilities
that are within our scope or written
broadly to influence and shape the
opportunity for better outcomes thank
you thank you thank you David and now
James the director of the McKinsey
Global Institute that's well thank you
Eric and delighted to be here this gonna
be interesting because we didn't
actually practice this we're gonna make
sure we taste slightly different things
so we'll see I looked at all their notes
and said everything they were gonna say
delighted to be here I think it is from
from my vantage point I mean when I when
I was doing my PhD and robotics
20 something years ago I never imagined
would make the kind of advances that you
all are contributing to this is an
amazing time and I think one of the
things that's striking about that is I
look at these questions from an economic
standpoint is that it is there's two
parts where I think it's relatively
clear why you know maybe three why these
things are these technologies and
innovations are great I think they're
good for business and business are gonna
benefit a lot they're gonna get
efficiency they're gonna get
capabilities that wouldn't otherwise
have that go beyond what humans can do
so
sludge do you say good for business I
think you can also largely say good for
the economy in the sense that you know I
think as David pointed out they can
contribute to the productivity growth at
a time
in fact we're gonna have aging
populations and there's a strong need to
have productivity contribute to economic
growth and prosperity so you could say
in that sense at least on the whole
largely good for the economy
you could also say good for what you
might call societal moonshots you're all
contributing to tackling diseases
climate science all those kinds of
things so all of that I think is mostly
good the question is what happens with
work and I think when it comes to work
let me describe a little bit some of the
studies we've done and the way we've
come as this question of work is to
start with tasks and activities as
opposed to start with hold jobs and if
you look at something there's lots of
good data whether it's the ownage
database and some of the other datasets
that we've got so we try to understand
you know looked at something like over
2000 specific tasks that people do in
the economy and we've also try to
understand something like 18 or 20
different capabilities of what
technology AI machine learning robotics
and sort of can now do everything from
analytical stuff to sensory motor
activities and so forth and you try to
look at all those things to see what
what looks like it's now possible and
the net of all of some studies that
we've done would suggest that if you
look at some economy something like
close to about half of the activities
not jobs to be clear the activities that
people do in the economy have the
potential to be ultimate the kind of
advances we're all creating now the
question and so the question then
becomes like a soul what kinds of
activities and what we find is that the
you know it's kind of like three kinds
of actives that look like they're
relatively easy to automate its
activities that involved a lot of data
collection a lot of analytical work
often and a lot of physical work in very
structured environment so you can
imagine it being routinized or arranged
to look like it's routinized so think
assembly line where you can actually set
things up to be exactly as you want the
lighting where you want it to be things
lined up exactly you bring some
structure machines can do that very well
so whenever activities kind of look like
that you know they're instance
whereas other things that are harder
that involved judgment and other things
are relatively hard other possible is
I'm sure some of you tell me that's you
working on general intelligence and
other things but you're this relatively
harder to do so the ones that seem
easier about half the time they're
chickens in the economy that makes up
close to trillion dollars in in wage
that goes to those jobs so the question
is okay so what does that mean for work
and how you spread now a lot of the
studies you'll have seen have tended to
look at just the technical feasibility
question which is what I've just told
you but there are other considerations
like how long does it take to actually
develop and deploy these technologies
how does this interplay with the labor
markets which is a question about
quality and quantity of labor supply and
the way does that go with them it's the
reason why something like say a
bookkeeper is a more likely occupation
to be automated than in Gardner because
keeping a gardener in the case of the
bookkeeper you know technically that's
all the easy it's mostly poor hopefully
potentially analytical work you can do
that with a relatively cheap of cuba's
standard software platform and so it's a
it's relatively easy to do a gun little
bit harder because they're probably
working outside a structured environment
yes
she's but it's more complicated
environment and less predictable one and
even if you do it you're looking for
machines of moving parts and all the
rest of it and the cost declines of that
aren't coming down quite as fast as just
standard software so you start to see it
and by the way for the gardener we pay
them a lot less the neighbors eyes large
more people are willing to do it
there are need certifications of
qualification so as you can see you're
poor likely to automate the bookkeeper
then you are the gardener for those
reasons say and so you go so when we've
looked at all of these and you start to
look at scenarios to say okay so what
does this all mean
the way we've kind of summarized looks
lots of God's work you might describe it
like this is the title of one of our
reports
lost jobs gained and jobs changed the
jobs lost part comes from the the
declines in occupations that are easy to
automate us more and more of those look
the jobs gained come from the fact that
you know when you offer when you get
productivity growth get economic growth
the economy is going to grow and it
creates jobs and and and so you go but
also other things that are gonna drive
job growth history as a divisions again
the rest of the walls gets a bit more
prosperous that drives demand so their
jobs that come from economy is growing
in several kind of demographic and other
factors that are going to create work
the jobs changed part comes from the
fact that if you look at these from a
tasks point of view as I said you know
the they're very they're relatively few
occupations that he's so far we're a
hundred percent of the constituent tasks
but there's a much larger number of jobs
so in our studies we found for example
that something like sixty percent of the
occupations have a part of third of
their constituent tasks that are ready
to be stored so that's just that more
jobs will change that will go away back
to the idea of complementing what humans
do and so forth so this idea of jobs
lost jobs gained jobs change seem to be
what's going on and a bit like David we
don't worry when we look at all those
scenarios because of course you can't
predict everything you don't know how
the piece of technology is gonna go
thanks to all of you
you know labor marks are gonna be
different from taste okay so you can't
fully predict everything we've done
scenarios trying to understand that it
looks to us that you know jobs gained
are gonna be far higher than the jobs
lost so we end up not at least in the
next you know a couple of decades or
thought about this so we end up not
worrying as much about you know would
there be enough work for everybody so
end up in the same place as David but we
do worry 500 for things that are
worrying that I were thinking about one
is even in a world where there's enough
work the number of occupational
that are probably going to happen are
quite significant this is as you see the
jobs decline and the others grow that
often requires equal change with
occupations and the one things that may
be different from previous periods is
that the pace of those occupational
changes may be a little bit faster than
previously so the scale of the
occupational changes is worried the
reason why that's worrying is because as
a society we have not proven to be very
good and assisting in helping people in
transitions or the shift or occupations
we've done some work everything we've
done all kinds of assistance and so
forth but the scale and pace of it means
we may not it's going to require to do
more than we've done to assist in those
occupational shifts the second thing
we're worried about is just a skill
shift one of the things you see as these
jobs both some declines some grow and
some change the the nature of the skills
that are actually demanded in terms of
the constituent elements of them are
quite different and so the demand of
skills goes up quite dramatically either
just because they are you need higher
skills or just in many cases just
different skills they may not be higher
Alaba they're just different so the
skill shift is quite substantial and the
reason the skill shift is quite worrying
is because that's one place where we
start we're starting in a hole already
you know there's already complains that
our educational systems don't work very
well with on trained workers very well
on-the-job training isn't as great as it
as it as it should be so we're already
starting in a hole where at a time when
we know we're going to need even more
skilling to support these skill shifts
so that's why we're worried about that
in by the way as a side note one of the
things that's quite fascinating is that
if you look at the OECD countries which
include the United States first of all
the United States rarely spends the
least on on-the-job training generally
we can debate about the effectiveness of
the but in terms of absolute dollars we
spend the least in terms of share of GDP
on worker on-the-job training and by the
way in most OECD countries over the last
20 years the amount of spend on worker
trends has been declining so we seem to
be starting in a whole grain in Reverse
at a time when
skilling is going to be even more
important so that's the second thing to
worry about the third thing we worry
about is the wage question and the
incomes that go with these jobs even in
a world in which there is work to be
done the wage question is potentially
troubling again at the time I'll already
have wage polarization the reason what
the wage question is interesting in an
age of air and automation is it is for a
couple of reasons one of them is the
fact that if you look at the
Occupational mix shift that we talked
about the occupant many of the
occupations that are declining have
actually started paid quite well versus
many the ones that are rising so if we
say care work and service work as David
is describing most of those occupations
on our great wage structures compared to
the ones that are declining so the
occupation mix shift by itself or may
create a wage problem the other place
where you get the wage question is and I
love when we as technologists and come
to myself as wondering you talk about
whether or not replacing jobs or
complimenting people I think it's
important to recognize it were me even
when technology complements people there
could be two kinds of outcomes in the
polar ends one end of the outcome is oh
is the outcome where somebody who's
skilled like all of you gets complicated
by the complimented by technology you
become more productive more interesting
your output is even better that's
wonderful there's also the other end of
the spectrum where if they complement if
the technology is complementing the
human who still has a job but the
technology's doing most of the
value-added portions of that job and
what's left over is relatively
commoditized and more people can
actually do that work and there's a much
it actually expands the labor pool
that's able to do that work we may
actually depress the wages even the
person still working so when we talk
about complementing work there's this -
there's this range of outcomes in wage
terms that may also create a bit of a
problem the weight set so anyway the
wage question is actually one that were
worried but again we're starting in a
bit of a hole on that already and so
this if this makes it worse then we have
a challenge so these are some of the
challenges that I think we're going to
need to think through as we navigate
this and I'm sure we'll talk about what
to do
there's two we have a couple comments
together from David and James we have a
project on that that farmer and
agricultural assistant called farm beats
that's actually going beyond the phone
tree but trying to do new things using
machine perception and planning
forecasting optimization to do
predictions for example about wendice
just to plant and when to and what parts
of the of the of the field should be our
over water and versus under water and so
on but I've always been ranged in
looking at these videos and the case
studies to understand what it is that
the the legacy operations and the
farmers think about this and they can't
really run these tools and so there's an
interesting mix even even coming out of
Microsoft Research Projects now and that
one just evolved to to Azure from MSR
Jason cannon from Kennedy School great
thanks so much for for having me here
and Eric left out the part of my bio
where I'm on the board of the
partnership on AI that we work out so we
get to know each other yeah together so
you know I was once on a streak I had
given like ten general interest talks in
a row things like student groups and
every single one of them I got the
question you know will a robot take our
jobs and then finally I broke spoke to a
group that broke my streak by not asking
that question and that was the judges of
the Southern District of New York who
were not very worried about this issue
but just about everyone else is
they've been worried about it for a
while
Eric slides made me jealous that I
didn't get to do a few of my slides if
he had let me I would have shown you an
article from 1980 in the New York Times
with the headline a robot is after your
job then I would have showed you a story
from The Wall Street Journal in 1960
robots rise they bid for big jobs both
in outer space and in US factories so in
1960 we were worried that we're gonna
lose all the like all the huge number of
outerspace jobs that we had to these
robots then I might have shown you
something in 1935 I think this was from
the early
of Microsoft thinking machines replace
the thinker they predict tides pick
criminals fingerprints calculate
mathematical problems and perform
amazing tasks so this is something we've
been predicting for a while and for the
most part that prediction hasn't come
true I'm mostly focused on public policy
and I think trying to base public policy
on predictions it seems like what you
should do but it's actually quite
fraught I think if we could just base
public policy on understanding what's
happening now and what's happened in the
past
we'll get sort of 85 or 90 percent to
where we want to go and then maybe we
can improve on that or with really bad
predictions make that worse and I think
too often we don't even do that you know
starting from where we are now and in
the recent past so that's what I'll do
now the first fact about now is you know
a week and a half ago we got the jobs
number for December and it was I think
three hundred and fourteen thousand jobs
that's an extraordinarily large number
of jobs created in the US economy on the
Department of Commerce is currently shut
down so we won't get the GDP number for
the fourth quarter until they reopen but
when they do it'll probably be in the
mid twos which is sort of okay mediocre
so spectacular job growth mediocre GDP
that's the exact opposite of the
automation concern that's a lot of
people a lot of people doing a lot of
work and not making a lot as opposed to
if you had automation you wouldn't see a
lot of jobs but you would see a lot of
GDP um
the when you divide the GDP by the jobs
you get something called productivity
and this is the paradox that
productivity growth has been quite slow
in techy circles people like to sort of
throw tomatoes when you say something
like that and doubt it I'm happy to have
a longer conversation about why I think
miss measurement doesn't explain this
we've always had miss measurement even
if he measured correctly you'd have
about as large and possibly even a
larger productivity slowdown then our
headline one just to understand why this
might be the case you know take lawyers
people talk about the automation of
discovery process and you know all the
different things that a I can do that
lawyers couldn't do there was a study I
think it was McKinsey for all I know I'm
miss quoting something James did that
found that each year you were able to
automate about one percent of the tasks
that lawyers had done the previous year
well productivity growth in the economy
for the last 50 years had been about two
percent two years that means every year
AI with lawyers is helping us get rid of
one percent of the things humans did
that's actually slowed a bit slower than
the pace it's sort of amazing because he
wouldn't have thought you could have any
productivity there we managed to squeeze
some productivity out of a part of the
economy wouldn't have thought you know
you can receive amazing stories on you
know robots that can pick tomatoes and
strawberries and other soft fruit that's
something that was really really hard to
mechanize in agriculture um that's not
going to give us a whole lot of
productivity growth because we've
already mechanized mechanized soybeans
corn we all the things that are 95
percent of what we do and so for a lot
of the economy it's enabling us to make
progress but it's enabling us to sort of
push things forward in places we
wouldn't have thought but not
necessarily at a faster pace cancer
research for example are making faster
progress on pancreatic and lung cancer
slower progress on almost every other
type of cancer for a simple reason we
sort of did the bigger easier things a
couple decades ago there may be an
inflection point just past where we are
now I'm not going to say there isn't one
but each year we see these data make me
sort of less and less convinced that
there's an inflection point so I think
there's sort of a lot of reason to think
the future is going to be like the past
that one of the biggest challenges we
have is we need more innovation more
labor saving technological progress but
I don't think we should be fully
reassured by the future being like the
past part of why we're gonna have jobs
in the future all the reasons that David
and James talked about part of why is
that people
compete with robots for jobs and they
can see their wages get lowered in order
to continue to have a job that's called
inequality and the mismatch between not
making the types of educational
investments that we had made earlier in
our history that David talked about and
technological change continuing meant
that you saw that rise in inequality so
that's sort of a scary reason that we
can cope with productivity a second
thing is yes every decade we've employed
more people than the last but if you
look at men between the age of 25 and 50
for precisely the opposite is true since
the 1950s and I like to do that because
that abstracts from cultural change it
abstract from institutional change and I
think in some ways gives you a little
bit of a more pure measure of how the
economy is doing without being you know
these are these other factors which are
really important and men went from
basically 98% in the workforce to about
88% in the workforce over a 60-year
period of time if you go earlier on the
transition from agriculture we managed
it better than we would have if we had
had no response at all but it was
enormous Lee dislocating and you know
played a role in World War 1 World War
two and all sorts of other things before
we got ourselves to the nice happy place
we are now so I think history can
reassure us on the losing half of our
jobs to automation or anything scenario
like that I don't think it can reassure
us that it won't take a big toll in
terms of inequality I don't think it can
reassure us that it won't chip away in a
road at the fraction of people working
and I don't think it can reassure us
about some of the broader social and
political ramifications of that change
you know in terms of you know I don't
think technological determinism is the
right lens to look at this through you
know a country like Italy has a very low
employment rate a country like
Switzerland has a very high employment
rate
if you were going off as a social
scientist to try to figure that out I
don't think you'd wander around Italy
looking for all the machines they have
that had replaced the people working and
think that like in Switzerland they were
making all the cuckoo clocks by hand and
that's why there was so much employment
there there's all sorts of color what
they are but they're look at cultural
things I look at economic policies I'd
look at institutions I wouldn't look at
all at technological differences and not
just between Italy and Switzerland
between any pair of countries if you
wanted me to explain their different
employment rates now I wouldn't do that
well that highlights for me is that
policy plays a really important role I
think institutions do and in culture
does I think there's things that we can
change or don't know how to change but I
think policy does and I think the fact
that a lot of countries have gone
through similar set of shocks and
transformations some of them have
handled them better than others with
better outcomes in terms of inequality
and labor force participation so that
then brings me to how we think about
public policy I have been to about 72
salon dinners to discuss the future of
work with James I've been to another
like 300 of them that he wasn't at and
I'm only slightly exaggerating and you
know i I've sort of mixed feelings when
it's framed as the future of work as I
said I think we have a really hard time
predicting the future the future is
coming a little bit less quickly then we
all think it is and I think the future
can be a pretty bad guide to thinking
about all of this because for example
you know what's happened to the
employment of people with stem degrees
versus people without people with stem
it's actually gone down in the last
decades people without who need
creativity management interpersonal
skills has gone up you think about the
future sort of makes you think about
math it makes you think we need to get
everyone training in math it's not
obvious that something like that is the
case I can't tell you about the next 10
years but if you don't know the fact
the last 20 years that well doesn't
disqualify you from participating in the
conversation but it's probably on the
minus side of the ledger you know other
reasons to think that it's hard to do
the future work we can't predict a lot
of people don't know what's happened in
the recent past in economics RCTs have
become increasingly important as a way
to evaluate public policies I think
they're especially important in things
like training programs job search
assistance and the like which have a
mixed record some of which work quite
well some of which don't you really need
to evaluate them
you cannot evaluate something ten years
in the future you can only evaluate
something on the economy today and the
economy is changing but it's not
changing you know per what I said before
quite as quickly as we might think most
people are in their normal jobs w2 and
the like I think we need to update our
policies for the growing part of the
workforce that's not in those jobs but I
think the bulk of our policies should
sort of focus on where the bulk of the
people are so I think if we try to get
our policies right for the present and a
recent past of work will be about 85%
correct you then want to be monitoring
that you want to think a little bit
forward one of the ways I've tried to
think forward is looking at the list
that researchers at Oxford at McKinsey
and elsewhere put of what occupations
are likely to be automated and one very
robust finding in those is not the
fraction of jobs it will be automated
which ranges from you know 15 or maybe
less to 50% but if you divide those up
and ask how many of them are
high-skilled how many of them are middle
and how many are low and that's quite
robust at a hundred and seventy two
dinners I had with James at a hundred
and sixty eight of them someone brought
up radiologists the first time they
brought up radiologists I was like wow
you know radiologists may be replaced by
machines by the hundred and sixty eighth
time I'm like wait that's the only
example we have of some
the medical profession that must mean
like there's actually a lot less of this
than I would have thought and by the way
even that example doesn't check out
because as we know it's the people
working together with the machines that
have much more effective ability to
diagnose rather than the machines
replacing the people so there are
examples at the high end when you go
through and just sort of crunch the
numbers and count them up
it's very robustly that the replacements
are very correlated with lower levels of
education lower levels of skill lower
levels of wages and that is a
continuation last 65 years I should have
said before you know the the men not
working going from 88% in the labor
force to 88% now those were college
graduates who would like cashed out sold
their company and like the spouse was
now working you know that might be fine
but these are men mostly with a high
school degree or less mostly without a
spouse at all let alone a spouse that's
working and I think automation could
mean a lot more for that and that's why
I'm sort of grateful we're having this
future of work conversation in some
sense it would have been just as timely
to have it in 1965 or 1975 or 1985 that
is it is in the Year 2019 as we were
seeing you know manufacturing jobs get
destroyed we didn't have as much of it
then and as a result I think we have
coped much less well when we should have
and we do need a substantial investment
of which education is far and away the
most reliable element and input into it
but a better set of connective tissues
to connect people for jobs train and
prepare people for jobs especially in a
place like the United States we don't
have quite the same you know
institutionally rich tissue of
apprenticeships labor unions a school
system dedicated to get people into jobs
how you can find public policies that
will reproduce that I think it's
particularly important great thank
thanks Jason and just to clarify one
thing you said but by Oishi T's you
meant
controlled trials and you are you
suggesting that you can actually do
large-scale policy experiments and get
some valid results for guiding policy I
think it depends if you're trying to do
your training program is it better to
show up you know one day a week or four
days a week and target this type of
person or that type of person the
general equilibrium isn't going to be
that important and so you can do an RCT
off of that you're trying to figure out
how to spend your money I'm not saying
there isn't any general equilibrium if
you're trying to do like a wholesale
social experiment of you know what is it
like with 90 percent unionization versus
40 percent versus it's a smattering
about I think that that might be quite
important for employment and inequality
lends itself less well to an RCT it just
just you know I'm MIT I'm Co directing
this initiative on on the work of the
future and there's a randomized control
trial component actually just received a
million dollar grant from the Gates
Foundation to support experiments on not
just on training but on how people you
know structure gig jobs on where where
should you people locate what are the
you know what are the how should
education be revitalized or readapted so
I think there's a lot of questions
they're not we can't run experiments on
the future we would like to but we can
run experiments on on helping people add
up adapt to changes and harness
opportunities okay great let's turn it
over to Sid from Microsoft Research
thanks Eric and also thanks for having
me it's a pleasure to be here in front
of everyone today I'm gonna jump off of
one of the points that Jason just made
and that was focusing a little bit more
on the here and now and let that guide
us forward so when I think of an AI
system I don't just think about the code
I think about the humans that provided
the training data and I also think about
the humans that step in when the AI
system doesn't know what to do so for
example everyone in this room knows that
imagenet fueled was a big part of the
fuel of the deep learning revolution but
what some of you might have forgotten is
that Mechanical Turk workers built image
now without them we might not have had
such progress another example would be a
common AI system as a chatbot what some
of you may or may not know is that when
a chatbot doesn't know how to answer a
question was it do it turns to the crowd
and often
and upwork worker to step in and answer
the question so that perspective is
gonna frame a lot of what I'm gonna talk
about today so right one of the things
that Mary and I did in our book is
realize that these people are hidden
behind api's okay Mechanical Turk
workers are hired through an API upwork
workers are hired through an API and
they're hidden and the end user doesn't
see them and maybe that's okay maybe
it's not but because they're hidden what
we wanted to do is bring them out into
the light shine a light of them say hey
there's these people they're doing this
work it's helping all of us how can we
support them so there's a few challenges
here number one is this work is really
neither full-time or part-time and in
the United States at least the social
safety net is often tied to employment
so these people aren't categorized
social fixation is tied to employment oh
oh now what there's no disability if
there's no unemployment there's no
there's no after-dinner drinks after
work drinks there's no Sunday softball
game it's a very sterile environment
this kind of work so that's that's one
sort of challenge one opportunity I see
this is going to touch on David's
barbell model where he was saying that
people and one end of the barbell are
gravitating towards service sector jobs
what we found in a lot of her interviews
what that we've done with these workers
we did over 200 of them was that a lot
of them were gravitating to this kind of
work because the best jobs where they
lived were Walmart McDonald's these
service sector jobs that you know the
hours can be unpredictable the benefits
may not be that great so they switched
to doing online on-demand work to sort
of provide a sort of pressure release
valve another upside that we found is
because when you do this work it is done
through an API
nobody often not in every platform but
often people don't know your personal
characteristics so now say you're part
of a discriminated class maybe that's
because if your race your gender your
religion your ethnicity what have you
well nobody in these labor markets often
they don't know that you're part of this
discriminated class so now you can get a
job so for example Mary interviewed a
Muslim woman in South India where it was
culturally let's say
look down upon to work outside the home
so what she did was she did this kind of
online labor from her home so that she
could contribute financially and she
took immense pride in this she can
contribute financially to her home and
sort of skirt the cultural constraints
of not being allowed to work outside the
home so those are some of the upsides
some of the downsides could this be a
kind of like a rich get richer
phenomenon in the sense that you know
rich countries the United States China
Russia etc have strong AI presence how
is that going to net out those countries
gonna then just I'm gonna turn to the
Economist answer this one or those
countries just going to get richer by
exporting that or could could you
imagine more sort of egalitarian outcome
yeah so yeah looking forward a bit you
know Eric gas is to sort of do that so
he yes just to look forward about about
thirty years that's a long time so
what's the price for surprises for
surprises surprises what last question
was what will surprise us over seventy
years not looking backwards so here's
Majan what will surprise you now so at
answer that question what i did was i
look back i look back thirty years
so what happened in what was going on in
nineteen eighty nine windows 3.1 was not
yet out the web was just invented by Tim
berners-lee and a 56k modem was like not
yet a thing okay so what if I'm gonna
look 30 years out and what might
surprise you I'm gonna have to look at
something that's kind of niche right now
but I think will become mainstream in
thirty years as looking back 30 years
guided me to do so the thing that uh one
thing I think will surprise us will be
currently it's very easy to get
information at a moment's notice the
internet did that for us I think in
thirty years we'll be able to get human
labor much more rapidly at our
fingertips than we are now
and I think that's going to be a big
deal and then finally I want to just
touch on a couple points by James and
David and the way I think about
automation is
is-is-is is the following there's always
these arguments about you know will we
get general intelligence will we reach
the singularity all of that
those are great arguments I leave those
arguments to people like Eric who are
smarter and wiser and older than I am I
[Laughter]
might agree on like two of those three
and so uh but the way I think about it
though is that argument kind of
overlooks the people now like I said who
are feeding into these automated systems
either by training data or or by
stepping in where they have low
confidence and that's what I want to
shine a light on and the other way I
think about automation is the following
and then you give a moment in time
there's a set of tasks that machines can
do that set of tasks grows as people
make advances well when it grows tears
exposed of tasks that we want to get
done but couldn't before
and that's often where the human labor
comes in and then as we make progress or
keeps advancing and I think looking at
the end limit is a fine thing to do but
I'd also like to look at the steps we
take as we get there thank you great
thanks and now moving on to Stephan for
perspective from Africa and beyond
well well thank you very much and being
the last one to to talk I'll also try to
make a couple of links between some
things that are being set as seen from
from developing countries which is my
focus and I could hear talk lyrically
about the incredible potential that
progress in a I could have from you know
health education delivery and I know a
great work is being done around this but
I think it's quite important to keep in
mind that well we could bring down the
cost of how to live a quality health
education to all these places if David
is right in saying you know that bottom
end there which is a lot in the
developing countries there no more jobs
there that's being squeezed out it's not
entirely and clear that that's a happy
outcome so so I want to make three
points and they are done in the spirit
of you know we should be first of all
realizing that
progress has been made including in
terms of living stamps in a developing
world in the last twenty years or so and
especially in parts of Asia and that has
been to a large extent driven as an
engine with exporting manufactured goods
and being part of global trade being
part of global value chains I'm not
saying it's all been beautiful and not
murky at times and so on but
fundamentally it was definitely one of
the key engines why these societies got
richer and then quite a few of them and
also managed to do some some important
things rate to poverty now many of the
things that are being said lead me to
imply that other as a road to
large-scale poverty reduction as a
strategy for a country to be able to do
this this is going to go away and so
this whole idea that this particular
remarkable development model that we had
since about 1990 until about 2010 and
from which we still see some of the
further consequences in a positive sense
especially in Asia that will somehow you
know stagnate it was really stagnating
one way global trade is not quite
expanding anymore but here the
automation a I kind of thing will make
this much less likely as a as a strategy
maybe not so much as an engine of growth
for these countries but as an engine of
further employment okay now I'm not too
worried about the countries that manage
to be part of what we call these global
value chains this part of you know from
China but also lots of these countries
connected to it also India South South
Asian countries and so on I'm less
worried about it because largely these
countries took off they becoming demand
centers and actually manufacturing will
probably keep on giving them jobs and it
can climb the value ladder they can also
automate can do things and actually you
know when you do this in a car in a
context when your economy is fast
growing these kind of these transitions
you can probably handle you can do
things so actually let's worry about
them but a place I'm most worried about
is is those countries in the developing
world that didn't manage to take
advantage of these these these
these processes which is basically
Africa so think of it you know it's
probably the best model we had in terms
of an economic point of view you know go
for exports of manufactured goods with
clear productivity ladders and such a
big source of employment in the
countries involved definitely as a
source of employment it goes away but
also if it all to do with AI in
automation it becomes harder to imagine
that these countries can actually really
get a foothold into it when they're not
started so so that's that's a worrying
thing and that's in spirit of also a
David set and the last thing that he
said you know kind of you know what will
happen with these countries at the
low-skilled labor that have no obvious
ladder that are being part of Inc and we
can do now I can't be working for
Melinda in terms of a commission not to
also try to be an optimist
that's obligatory and we'll have to do
that but it's quite useful because I
think that perspective that it's all to
do with what's been happening in
manufacturing and then the automation
have been happening around the factory
floor forget something and I thinks it
was already alluding to it and others as
well is that there is an also another
important part of what a lot of these
new technologies are doing which is not
just optimizing production technologies
on the factory floor getting much more
efficient ways of translating the inputs
into outputs and letting a robot do
certain things but actually having
mechanisms to increase much more the
allocation efficiency in your economies
locally nationally globally so and that
since we forget they haven't Smith when
he talked about growth was always about
that
it was not about the technological
progress on the factory floor and I will
move out he talked about getting the
allocation better in in in economies now
that's an important part of it you know
I can think of it you know what you're
talking about in terms of labor location
that's not just national but potentially
globally you know you can having a much
better connectivity and now it's and
here it comes down to two forces that
you know and then it becomes crystal
ball gazing here we have to worrying a
bit about it one is is is the
technological
that are going to come is it largely
going to be of the type of the
automation the automation of taking
tasks away from people and removing more
people out of doing things and and
somehow AI has automation or are we
actually going to get very much better
progress in communication technologies
first that allows people to do all kinds
of work far more from a distance because
then the reasons why you know initially
in this global valid change and China
and Thailand and and Bangladesh and so
on could be part of it
how do not to do because there was just
enough good communication with all these
places that it could be done remotely
and if you can keep on improving that we
can imagine a situation where maybe
existing manufacturing global value
chains become be less important but
actually new ones can emerge and not
least in terms of some some services
provision now I don't know this is
crystal ball gazing or how these two
things will will trade off but you can
imagine and I sometimes think that in
due course you know with human human
voice is becoming scarce err in our own
economies who labor scarcity and aging
and I'll be retired sitting somewhere
somewhere in my retirement home well
actually a few more voice will come from
Bangladesh and I'm sure you'll have some
AI that may sound as if it's British or
Belgium where I'm from and I can
actually communicate and thinking I'm
talking to someone that this comes from
my background but there can be somewhere
else and they can do it and that's not
necessarily a bot but it can be enabled
and you can imagine much more
complicated service provision being done
remotely as part of processes and much
more processes that you know isn't be
more decentralized so you could imagine
something they are happening that could
be a positive thing okay so also
similarly and I think that's where
sometimes a little bit less worried
about developing worlds then maybe I
would be saying UK of Sheffield or here
certain parts is that you know you're
starting solo okay you know when we
talking here an uber job in a
every job will just eat job sounds like
not very good you know when I work in
Africa the informal sector it sucks it
totally sucks it's the worst type of
world you can have you total have total
job uncertainty you have no connectivity
you can't find it you have no way of
allocating your labor you sitting idle
waiting for opportunities and meanwhile
it's incredibly low so actually getting
some of these kind of things started you
merge getting these a location
efficiency saying cities or between
rural and urban areas to start working
better that that's actually is progress
it's not great but it is actually
progress so it's pride the interesting
thing that you know is a paper
forthcoming in the American Economic
Review that says well lot of the
predictions that we have about you know
technology and an internet coming into
economies they may be similar but be
probably one exception they found that
the access to high-speed Internet in
African countries 12 countries actually
increased employment formal employment
across all skill levels more so for the
skilled parts the usual prediction with
the bottom end you know it's better than
the kind of jobs that you were having
and so you can actually move up a bit
and you can skating some of these
dynamics as well so so in that sense you
know it's not like so there's that and
so it's these two things what can happen
in in economies on its own and also
globally that they may actually be
global connectivity because that labor
is still fundamentally cheap and maybe
it can be part of these these kind of
things so sometimes I'm a bit more
worried about the kind of lower still
dead here because there are maybe
because of increased opportunities of
both getting more efficient allocation
and better communication to allocate
that from all over the world and that's
the kind of thing so come to the policy
things so you know one thing though why
this may not happen is that when I work
on African countries you know maybe I
worried that we are not prepared here
you know these countries are absolutely
not prepared for this you know the basic
you know digital readiness of these
countries is surprisingly low they are
living entirely in fear and they're
reading some of these reports and they
get even more scared but there
very little constructive advice what can
they actually do in their own countries
and I think of for example two things
you know it is the case for example that
we may assume internet connectivity all
of the world's connected no it's
probably about three billion people in
the world that are not connected and we
were looking at the response of
commission I can't see a business model
that is currently used that will get
them to be connected right quickly you
know I was in in China talking to Y way
maybe one shouldn't anymore but anyway I
was talking to them and asking what you
think will be your sheepish phone you
will deliver in African so it won't get
cheaper as this hundred dollars now that
people can't afford that data is
incredibly expensive in these places so
these three billion it's not because
there's no mass and mobile phone
connectivity they just found gets access
to these kind of things so that's of one
thing another part of it basic
governance you know these countries are
scared and they do all kinds of fairly
random things in terms of how to
actually start start governing things
and finally things that I would worry
about you know this is I think a
potential you know maybe it's too
positive a vision but I think there will
be countries that actually will be able
to take advantage I think it happened
with the previous process of global new
changes in global value chains there
were a few surprises you know it was a
famous one goon our mirror doll Nobel
Prize winning economist but he wrote
about the Asian drama I said and he
worried about Africans they have no idea
with Africa maybe some countries will
become successful but one country I can
be sure of will never be successful in
in the world will be Mauritius now it's
probably the one that managed to get
into global value chains again here
there will be will be surprises but I'm
very worried that there is going to be a
son of a Trump at some point that
basically will be policymaking in the
rich countries that actually says oh
that kind of globalization of labor the
opportunities from there we will not
allow it we will close you're from this
kind of opportunities as well and so on
you know and we'll need to be very
careful on it and then I would be I
think that's when I would be worried in
ten 15 years from now on the future
especially the African continent
well thank you thank you to all the
panelists some open it up to questions
and comments from the audience in from
one another to each other
I'll just kick off by by reacting to
some of what I mostly heard with from
Jason but others as well so as a
graduate student I worked on when my
projects was Bayesian diagnostic models
for troubleshooting the reaction control
system in space shuttles NASA mission
control and these are the all those Jets
that keep the shuttles stable when it
was flying in orbit and so on and
deorbiting and so on and I view that
your comments Jason is saying well let's
just look in the past and stay in the
present take our economic models and be
reactive with these micro controls as we
go and we'll just see what happens and
do our best with the current economic
models and theories that we have but
when it comes to the learnings of the
past where there have been waves of if
we can generalize there have been big
waves of fairly fast paced changes in
automation why is it the steam engine
and all the belts and gears and pulleys
of that whole world and the frame
breaking and like the other waves
mentioned will or one or two potentially
contributory factors can't we give
larger things now to be more proactive
we figure out what kind of data we
collect things we do large-scale
controlled studies that really aim at
bigger grain sizes for preparing
ourselves given jumping to a level of
reflection that we know how these things
tend to go and we want to be a little
bit more proactive as we're all here
about decisions as an opinion on this
question first of all I wouldn't say
don't worry just do small little
tinkering things I think we should do
quite a lot I think this is a major
issue I just think you know the
experience the last twenty years and the
problems the last twenty years are
enough motivation to do a lot I don't
need someone to paint some picture of an
inflection point in the future to
motivate me to do
their first thing second thing I'm
partly no reacting and things like ubi
which I view as a sort of fantastic
expand acronyms oh sorry I'm universal
basic income where everyone gets a fixed
amount of money every year and you know
the sort of numbers don't add up the
premise is that we're not going to have
any jobs whereas I'd be really quite
shocked if 30 years from now most people
aren't working sort of roughly the same
hours that they are now and you know so
I think that sort of often justified
based on predictions that I think gets
sort of way ahead of where we are now so
yeah so I think you know in these RCTs
we do randomized control trials for
those last time you know so weight them
towards part of the economy that we
think will be bigger in the future
rather than will be smaller in the
future to try to be collecting data in
real time about the things I'm saying to
grapple with this question a
productivity growth measurement and
what's happening with it I think all of
those are important think we should be
doing big stuff but I just wouldn't yeah
I have no problem we're debating the big
stuff from the price I should jump in
though which is on the UVI point so what
I ask them with yeah I'm gonna try and
like ubi but I like the debate and
discussions provoking which is causing
us to have to think about you know do
people earn enough to live so I'm
actually in favor of wage subsidies of
some sort there are links to people you
know doing something right whether it's
you know they're working but just on
earning enough Sadri subsidised wages in
some form or fashion yeah the other big
thing I'm also in favor of doing
something about one of the things that's
quite striking is if you look at how our
economy works we don't do you know we've
figured out ways to encourage the system
with its companies and others to invest
in things like capital I mean capital
investments they were allowed people to
depreciate them to to write them off and
you know we give you know Rd tax
deductions of once or another to
encourage investments in those things
which is a good thing for those
companies and for the economy we don't
do anywhere close to as much on the
human capital side so most companies
today when you when you pay for and
spend money on worker training that's
in expense you don't typically write-off
quite as much so there's just something
about can we do more on the human
capital side to encourage the kind of
investments especially the time when we
know you know system-wide rate generally
are spending less companies and the
public sector is generally spending less
on worker training said so one piece of
your question that Jason also alluded to
was you know what should we be measuring
that we're not right now looking a
little forward you can't study what you
don't measure you can't study what you
don't count and there's not a lot in my
opinion of good data about and a good
data about you know what jobs being
created by a eyes what jobs are being
displaced are those jobs that are being
displaced are the jobs are being created
are they for the people who got
displaced or differ a different set of
people James has done you know the the
best work you can possibly do with the
data we have David and some of
colleagues have as well but like I think
that the data quality here is not what
any of us would want and I think a much
more concerted large-scale effort there
would be welcome from the C s
perspective as well
okay the audience is you don't need to
define you don't need to define C I may
be for the for the outside audience my
panelists thank you very much this is
very engaging discussion I have a
question for you for the disability lens
there's a lot of data that's pointing
out about mainstream employment very
much sketchy data throughout the eras on
people with disability if you have a
magic wand to take advantage of 1
billion people with disabilities in
their talent for the next foreseeable
future what would you do to help this
module marginalized group become a more
active participant in the workforce
thanks Jennifer your question yeah
so one of the things we actually found
in our interview data was that people
with disabilities who again are often
part unfortunately so of a discriminated
class we found them doing on-demand work
for example I was a gentleman in in in
India he he was paralyzed from the waist
down and nonetheless he was he was his
mind was completely sharp and he was
working away contributing to his family
and it was a heartwarming story um yeah
I there's in theory you should never
there we should be in the best possible
time for people with physical
limitations to do meaningful work
because there's so many ways that we can
augment compensate for specific you know
limitations the you know like for
example but in Japan there's a
restaurant that staffed by robots that
are controlled by people with
disabilities who are in the back and in
fact think those are their kind of those
are their automata the in the u.s.
ironically after the passage through the
American with Disabilities Act the
employment population rate of adults
with self-reported work limitations fell
for 20 years consecutively
it is now risen again a lot in the last
five or seven years two forces behind
that one is the tightening labor market
another actually changes in disability
policy in the Social Security
Administration that have been much less
accommodating and much more demanding so
I you know I think that you know the
irony is this should have this problem
should have been getting better for a
long time and that's a failure the the
upside is clearly there's enormous
potential to have because of machine and
I expect you know not just the store you
know traditionally working on the
population all of us will have you know
you know back limitations motor
limitations that we can compensate for
with you know robotics and so on so I
imagine people will also have longer
productive lives as they you know make
adjustments for the inevitable
deterioration of physical health yeah
James you mentioned lack of work
training in America but it seems like as
people live longer and Technology chains
more rapidly as people age past their
education page they will slowly become
less skilled in the future so like at 20
you may know this fine edge technology
at 40 you may not so like how do we
think about that not just from the bike
company training perspective where it
might be cheaper for them to just
replace you know aging people but also
from like a a personal development
perspective where you may need
reeducation or something like that yeah
and I actually think it's one of the
questions that I think it's um doesn't
that easy answers to because it's easier
to describe the problem which is we need
lifelong learning but one of the things
that's actually been prevalent
difficulties at least in recent times
have been very few very large-scale
learning initiatives that have kind of
worked well the things I'm always struck
by is when you when you look at all
these rescaling initiatives quite often
most of the examples you come across
tend to be very small yeah we train down
to people with transferred work so that
so the doing this at scale is actually
but very hard and also just creating a
culture of and mechanisms that allow
lifelong learning now there you could
argue how well it's done and Eric you
probably have a view on this given
soldier medical connections some
professors of all said these lifelong
learning things built in continuing
education and requirements in those core
recertification although and so forth
that hopefully create incentives for
people to go back and relearn what they
think they know already or recertify or
whatever have you so I don't know
whether some package of incentives but
also capabilities and mechanisms people
to keep learning can be built in one of
these I worry about the lifelong
learning is that there's some
interesting empirical evidence and some
work has been done I think was at
Columbia that showed that you know as
much as we talk about rescaling a
socio-economic it's actually quite hard
often for people in their 50s for
example to choose to do that
they've done some empirical work which
is the incentives and motivation to go
back they're not you know now this is
I'll give you some a self-selected group
you probably all motivated to learn but
if you when the empirical studies that
they've done would suggest that we
shouldn't assume that everybody in that
position in age range who want to do
that so so there's a question there also
questions about motivation re commitment
and in some cases the skills remember
not all these skill requirements are
simply higher skills they may just be
different skills so can you take some of
these studies show that can you take
somebody who's working on an assembly
line and get them to learn to be a
caregiver they may not be as motivated
to do that for whatever social cultural
reasons versus working in a factory for
example so I think we have to think
about some of those social dynamics of
rescaling and relearning even when we've
got the capabilities and the
opportunities and the mechanisms in
place so I just think it's been
complicated were you working at ASCO but
one of my colleagues David Deming has a
recent paper and he finds that the
phenomenon you're talking about varies a
lot across occupations and if you look
at people with stem degrees who work in
computer science they start with higher
wages and their wages actually fall or
don't grow nearly as rapidly as someone
in something where you know like nursing
which sort of starts a bit lower and
grows and the difference is in the first
the skills depreciate more quickly as
the language has changed etc and it's
sort of easier and cheaper to hire
someone trained in the latest and
greatest than to go with the I don't
know if is the age wisdom or
intelligence which of the two of those
three and you know where as a nursing
sort of confronting more and more
different and varied types of cases and
learning some of the tale ones and and
all of that can matter more so I think
this varies across occupations the
second thing sort of building on what
James said in terms of public policy for
people past their mid 50s I think we
need something that McConnell is called
wage insurance which is you know if you
lose your job we give you insurance what
if you lose your $80,000 your job and
the only job you can get is $40,000 a
year we can give you half the difference
for five years if you're above a certain
age you know $20,000 zero or something
like that I think that's one of the
adverse things that can just happen to
you and if it happens to in your 30s
figure I had to get you back on your
feet and on an upward trajectory if it
happens to aged 59 you know rather than
going on disability insurance and
figuring how to get on to that or giving
up entirely insuring against that
eventualities I think it's a missing
piece of our social safety net David
that that Deming insight is a surprise
to me but we'll put it up here it's an
NBER working paper and it's know we sort
of something that I think I mean David
may have an opinion on I think like that
tires need to be kicked on it I would
like say it's a hundred percent true yet
but but yes I think it was really quite
interesting he also found by looking at
burning glass date on job postings that
you know they're changing jobs are
changing less rapidly and his estimate
rather than more rapidly but standoffish
issues with that but STEM jobs have very
high rates of tax locks right so what's
what happens in STEM job changes so fast
and that's probably one of the reasons
why the skills you know seem to have a
shorter shelf life right I see can I
make one oh yes David I'm sorry yeah you
know the this would make you tend to
make think oh my god you know older
workers must just be really screwed in
this rapidly moving economy but that's
not true at all and in fact labor force
participation rates of nearly elderly
adults have risen a lot they've done
better than the young especially the
educated ones so you know part of it you
we're in a period where we're in a
demographic crunch and there are
relatively few young people the
workforce is aging and but that in some
sense creates more demand you know
because you can fill as you know for
highs for educated older people they'll
have longer working lives that's a good
thing um the challenge really is for
less educated adults who are displaced
on career jobs those are the folks who
you know people who are displaced from
you know factory work or people who are
displaced from you know transportation
work and their skills must maybe
much less malleable so this is not I do
not think a first order problem for the
you know the near majority of older
adults who have some college education
but it is for a lot of other folks and
so I think we should not be too out of
you know apocalyptic about this strongly
agree on that I but it's sort of I think
you probably agree sort of 10-15 percent
definitely so so the stick to give to
some some wake towards the people online
we have a quite a few people coming in
on on the team site question from the
outside audience
this weekend's New York Times had a
fascinating story about cities and the
future of work based on professor our
tours work
I'm I didn't work outside of cities near
rural and far rural as the new book
hinterland defines it and David and said
well AI and the future of work be good
or bad for rural people given the
previous election which were all voters
had great impact this question seems
quite important yeah I mean so one of
the I'm sorry go ahead
the I mean I think one of the big
surprises you know to a lot of people
including economist was you know the
whole you know death of distance that
hasn't happened right you know we are
more you know we have so many more ways
to communicate and to simulate
interpersonal interactions and yet
agglomeration the need to be close
together seems to be more important and
you know like you know I work in Kendall
Square at MIT if you want to be a
biotech startup you can't be more than a
mile from my office right which seems
crazy and so it is increasingly
information intensive work is
concentrated in a few places and that's
the best work there is at present so I
think for for you know if you're gonna
be retired rural areas are gonna be
great right because you know you could
all the entertainment can be tapped in
you can get stuff delivered you can
imagine it increasing monitoring so on
but seems like for productive acting you
know for like mainly you know we're
activities somehow are you know density
has become more not less important and
that's where the high wages are for
highly skilled people although there are
fewer and fewer opportunities for people
without high levels of skills they don't
no longer benefit from proximity they no
longer do the skilled in a straight of
work they no longer do the skill
production work they're mostly just you
know caregivers of you know
givers so I think it's a it's a
challenge and it obviously has electoral
consequences right there's been a huge
inversion of the age structure of
population across areas such that it
used to be in the 1950s you know low
density areas were younger than cities
by considerable amounts like five or six
years in the ensuing 60 years low
density areas have aged about 12 years
in the cities of age about two years and
so there's been a complete inversion the
gradient was as you went from low to
high density age looked like this and
now it looks like this and so if you
want to find a dynamic place where there
corruptions cities are young and highly
educated and they've changed enormous
Lee so I think that creates real
challenges and I think we have not when
we focus on inequality we tend to talk
about the distribution of income but the
distribution of opportunities across
space I think has been less studied but
turns out to be you know quite wants
control so that's uh just a jump off
that you know David mentioned that you
know if you do biotech and in
Massachusetts you have to be within a
mile of his office so I don't do what
yeah so I'm a mile and a half yeah you
know so I could rent my office to
someone one of the projects I recently
started with Scott counts here in MSR
was the following it's you know as David
said cities act as attractors for
skilled labor and the research question
were asking here
well does the gig economy provide a sort
of mitigating factor here so if you're
not you know if you do have you know
skills to contribute but you don't
happen to live in one of these high
density areas as you pointed out can you
still contribute through the gig economy
and that's something that we're working
ok yeah James yet a comment no no I was
gonna I was gonna make comment that one
of the things that's quite fascinating
when you look at the economy cities are
actually getting in larger and larger
share the economic large s in a very
persistent way so there's something like
we just in the paper called superstars
which Jason was involved in something
like this about 50 cities in the world
that now capture something like 28
percent of the world's economic
valuation
this is a much larger number than they
used to be and those that's becoming
more persistent actually over time so
there's a strong regionalization to
these Walt effects which maybe is driven
by the density that David is talking
about but within those cities you then
have these massive wage differentials
actually they seem wider in the cities
in these superstar cities than they are
in rural areas so your ears don't do as
well but it's the the polarization is
not as wide its cities do spectacularly
well and the proposition is widest here
David James Jason you guys have all
mentioned it's pretty persistent and so
I kind of like to double back to the
point that you may save it which was
about farm states and how there was
mandatory schooling at age 16
dude through the guys think that there's
a real world you know equivalent today
that we could do and is as simple as you
know just more STEM education or is a
mandatory pre-k or what are some of the
things you guys are seeing from the data
you've gathered that you know couldn't
we could use to perform education in the
I think it was a 2013 State of the Union
the single worst polling proposal was to
make age 17 mandatory for school
assign the Alan Krueger who is my
predecessor at the Council of Economic
Advisers one of the leading education
labor economists thought the evidence
was very good for in general I think
there's a lot to adding the amount of
time and education and you can do it at
age three and four where the United
States Senate number 22 out of the OECD
countries and the percentage of three
and four-year-olds in school and you can
do it at the other end in terms of
longer high school or college the you
know some of that requires units require
more money and more investment than
we've done as compared to other
countries hey Elizabeth
continuing on the higher education so
there are a lot of salons and things on
the future of higher education and of
course Harvard MIT jumped in and crazy
Epic's you know there's been a lot of
push towards online education with
Udacity Coursera so that was like five
to seven years ago and now is sort of
like looking forward you know there was
all this discussion about for your
education the four-year degree kind of
going away and moving toward like micro
credentials micro masters my micro
bachelor's degrees I'm just curious what
your guys thoughts are higher education
before your university degree but the
four-year degree has gone away it's been
replaced by the five and six-year degree
which is how much time the typical
student takes to complete their college
education um the online education is
about an economics PhD yeah no no that's
that's that's the ten year degree online
education has not yet been a success and
in fact it's it's been disabled izing
the people who are good at or the people
who already good in traditional
environments and feel bad about as
everybody else and the evidence so far
is that you know students get less out
of it they're less engaged they're less
likely to complete on the other hand
there's clearly opportunity we haven't
found this special sauce yet right but
it's it's hard to believe that there's
just like nothing useful that can come
out of that so clear there must be and
we haven't found the right set of you
know compliments of human interaction
versus online supports and so I'm like
so I for example one I would think MIT
should have an online year for every
student like instead of it and then we
could increase the number of students we
admit by third I think it's crazy that
they all have to spend four years MIT
but let me talk about a more meaningful
subject you know one thing that we're
doing one of my colleagues Esther Duflo
and I'm chief energy you might have
heard that they wrote core economics
have done is they created what we call a
blended master's program in and in
development decisions in public policy
and the way it works is we have our EDX
courses which are which are free and you
can take we have a quite now of a
two-year online curriculum is quite
rigorous and if you pay a little bit of
money you can get certified you go to a
testing center so on among the people
who do the very best in that they can
apply to then complete is and they get
they get an MIT X degree which is worth
brought what you paid for it and then
they but they can apply and come do
another residential semester at MIT and
get a master's degree from MIT in this
field and that opens a funnel for talent
that would
ever be feasible for a place like MIT
and I imagine many others people come
over it will be you know people who are
policy makers in developing countries
they'll be paid for by Gates Foundation
in other places and it creates a new
pipeline an opportunity and exposure so
I think that's one small model um so I
think they're more of that needs to be
done I I think there's there's hope that
we can that there's a lot of possibility
excellent way in the back yeah about
globalization and hiding people behind a
pis or people on demand or mechanical
torque etc clearly in different
countries or different locations people
are because of minimum wages or cost of
living people are willing to work for a
lot less and because of this
colonization you're competing with
employees from every country for these
lower education simpler jobs the
mechanical torque replaces wasn'ta
create a bigger inequality how come we
protect but still believe this
distribution of wealth which is good so
how do you balance it out so there's you
definitely see labor wage labor and wage
arbitrage on these sites and I want to
point out it's not just micro test sites
like Mechanical Turk its macro test X
leg up workers well you know you can
hire a developer from Romania and pay
him less than an American dveloper would
charge
ok I'll leave it to the economist to
tell me about the freedom there I mean
it's almost equal to really I mean look
you know what you see it from the point
of view of these poor countries you see
less of a problem than then the way you
see it when you have an audience
somewhere in the US so you know we can
only observe that global trading goods
over the last 20 years have an enormous
equalizing force here is the first time
that earnings in Asia were beginning to
converge back to what happened in OECD
countries you know I would celebrate
that you know that's a great thing that
they
going up and getting close and you know
that's across the skill distribution and
you know there's internal inequality
issues but it's there so you know you
you need to ask your question oh yeah or
even the ethical point of view what is
the trade-off between this you know do
you do you how do you handle the
disruption that this may have here
bye-bye you know because in a sense what
city's talking about is that labor
becomes incredibly increasingly tradable
even though people don't have to move
anymore you know actually to just an
interesting statistic that I recently
saw is that you know take a country that
used to get most of its export earnings
from trading people literally
Philippines remittances was the biggest
source of foreign exchange and from
export earnings actually net next year
this is likely to be internet-enabled
services and IT services so that
actually and that's just the same the
same thing that we're seeing rather than
people moving you're allowing goods to
moving services move and it's an
equalizing force but you know look the
disruption and so it gets in your
societies it's it's it's a choice sir
but I have less problem with the end of
an issue race through it because you
know there's these huge inequalities
that I also want to just take a flip
side of the market for a minute another
thing I've done is I've interviewed
about me or my team has interviewed
about 70 some people full-time employees
at Microsoft at Microsoft but also other
enterprise companies in the United
States hiring out labor and those people
eight people in this room I'm talking
about and those people it's in the front
of their mind what are the ethics of
this is this a race to the bottom that
I'm contributing to and this is not
something that's like sort of hidden in
the background or anything they're
really thinking about it deeply and
they're waiting for Microsoft or you
know senior management to come with a
cohesive you know sort of policy and
perspective on on that
okay so let's it's great to see that
there are still hands going up as we hit
the 11 o'clock endpoint we'll have a
little bit of time up here people to
come up in this meat meat and talk and
ask your questions directly to the
panelists but I want to thank David and
James and Jason Sid and Stephane thanks
very much
thank you everybody
[Applause]